المترجم: Fatima El Kerchaoui
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
أيها الإخوة والأخوات الكرام
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
وأسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير
يسرني ويشرفني في الحقيقة أن أكون
متواجداً ومشاركاً لكم في هذا المحفل
وأشكر جميع القائمين على تنظيمه.
طبعا النجاح عبارة عن غاية
كل واحد فينا يسعى إلى تحقيق هذه الغاية
سوى أن كان ذلك في مسيرته الأكاديمية
أو في مسيرته المهنية
إلا أن الطريق الموصل إلى النجاح
دائما ما يكون مليئ بالمصاعب
ومليئ بالمتحديات ومليئ بالمعوقات
وتخطي هذه المصاعب
يحتاج إلى الكثير من المثابرة
والعمل الجاد
والجهد الوافر
وتقديم التضحيات والتنازلات
وطبعا نحن لنا في أبائنا وأجدادنا
أسوة حسنة
لماذ؟
لأنهم تمكنوا في الحقيقة من التغلب
على الكثير من المصاعب والتحديات
رغم قسوة الحياة
رغم الظروف القاسية التي مروا بها
لم يكن التعليم متوفراً في تلك الأيام
ولا وسائل الاتصلات كانت متوفرة مثل اليوم
فكان الكثير منهم يضطر أن يسافر
من أجل أن يتعلم
وكان الكثير منهم يضطر أن يسافر
من أجل أن يعمل
ومع ذلك نجح
نجحوا في تعليمهم،
نجحوا في عملهم،
نجحوا في تجارتهم
تحضرني في الحقيقة قصة رجل
توفي قريبا -رحمة الله عليه -
هذا الرجل امتهن التجارة منذ أن كان طفلاً
فكان يسافر إلى دول
مجاورة إلى السعودية إلى الكويت
من أجل أن يقوم بأعمال بسيطة
فمثلا كان يبيع أشياء بسيطة مثل الفحم
ففي إحدى المرات وهو يبيع الفحم
في إحدى شوارع الدمام بالسعودية
كان يوم شديد الحرارة
أتاه أحد السكان وأشفق عليه
فهو كان طفلا أيامها عمره إحدى عشر سنة
فاستوقفه ذلك
وقال له: "من أين أنت؟"
قال له: "أنا من إمارات الساحل"
فقال: "طيب! هل أمك موجودة على قيد الحياة؟"
قال: "لا"
قال له: "لو كانت أمك موجودة على قيد الحياة
لما سمحت لك بأن تقطع كل هذا الطريق
لكي تبيع الفحم
وتعمل بهذه الطريقة
إذا تخيلوا حجم المعوقات التي وجهوها
في تلك الفترة
اليوم اختلف الوضع طبعا
نظرا للتطور الهائل
الذي نشاهده في كافة مناحي الحياة
فالطريق الموصل إلى النجاح
أقل وعورة وأبسط من ذي قبل
يستطيع أي شخص فينا الآن
أن يستغل كافة التقنيات الموجودة
المعطيات التقنية، التقنيات المعلوماتية
يستغلها لكي يطور قدراته،
يطور إمكانياته العلمية، قدراته الإنتاجية
وبالتالي ينجح ويستمر ويواصل حياته
إلا أن مع ذلك
يجب أن يفكر الإنسان كيف يتعامل مع الظروف
التي يمكن أن يواجهها في المستقبل
التي يمكن أن تعترض طريقه إلى النجاح
كيف يمكنه أن يتعامل مع الظروف
التي قد تعتريه؟
قد يواجه الإنسان ظروف مادية معينة،
ظروف أكاديمية، ظروف صحية وغيرها
إلا أنه كما ذكرت
بالمثابرة والجد يستطيع أي شخص
أن يتغلب على الظروف مهما كانت
طيب، ماذا لو كانت الظروف التي تمر بالإنسان
ظروف استثنائية، ظروف غير عادية
كيف يمكنه أن يواجهها؟
إنه لمن الطبيعي أن يصاب الإنسان في حياته
بمرض لا قدر الله
يتعرض إلى حادث
يفقد فيه حاسة من الحواس مثلاً،
عضو من أعضائه، طرف من أطرافه
كيف يمكنه أن يتغلب على مثل هذه الظروف؟
كيف يمكنه أن يواصل مسيرة النجاح
فيما لو واجه مثل هذا الظرف؟
في الحقيقة هناك عدة أمور:
أولاً، لابد أن يتقبل الواقع الذي هو فيه
لابد أن المحيط الذي حوله
المجتمع لا ينظر له نظرة سلبية
يجب أن يزرع فيه الثقة مجدداً
يجب أن يحفزه على الواقع
يجب عليه أيضاً أن يفتش
عن مكامن القوة التي فيه
أحياناً الإنسان حتى إذا مر بمثل هذه الظروف
قد تكون فيه مكامن القوة الموجودة
ولا يعلم بحاله كثيرٌ من الناس
يقول: "لا يا أخي، هذا يعيش حياة تعيسة"
وحياة صعبة، ليس له أمل
لا يتقبل هذا الأمر
الحياة صعبة عليه
أنا تحضرني قصة
شخصية أمريكية
اسمه دايان بلازي
تخرج من كلية الهندسة
وأصبح مهندساً إلكتروني
وبعدما أمضى تقريباً أربعة سنوات
من حياته العملية تعرض إلى حادث
فقد خلاله البصر
وفكر: "أنا فقدت نعمة البصر
ولكن الآن لدي مكمن قوة
غير متوفرة عند الآخرين
المؤهل الذي حصلت عليه
في الهندسة الإلكترونية
يسمح لي بأن أوفر حتى لو كنت في هذا الظرف."
فماذا فعل؟
أسس شركة سماها "بلازي إنجينيرينغ"
تخصصت هذه الشركة في صناعة
وتطوير التكنولوجيا المساعدة
أو "Assistive technology"
لذوي الإعاقة البصرية
وكانت هذه الشركة من أنجح الشركات
وبعد تقريبا عشرة سنوات من تأسيسها
اندمجت مع شركة أخرى
وشكلا مجموعة "Freedom scientific group"
والتي تعتبر الآن أكبر مصنع ومطور
للتكنولوجيات المساعدة لذوي الإعاقة البصرية
من ضمن الأشياء التي طوروها مثلا
حلول القراءة أو "Reading solutions"
هي عبارة عن "scanners"
وعن كاميرات مزودة بأنظمة صوتية
كل ما عليك فقط هو أن تضع عليها الكتاب
وتبدأ هذه الأجهزات بقراءته بشكل مباشر
فتخيلوا أن الملايين من ذوي الإعاقة البصرية
حول العالم
استفدوا من عمل دايان بلازي
نتيجة إصراره وعدم توقفه
استمر رغم الظرف الذي تعرض له
أحيانا يواجه الإنسان ظروف معينة في حياته
يشعر بالتقاعس
يستهين بقدراته
يستهين بإمكانياته
وتناسى وفي الحقيقة هو لم ينسى،
بأن الله سبحانة وتعالى
خلق كل إنسان وهو يتمتع بقدرات خيالية
طاقات كامنة دفينة في الإنسان
قد لا يكون الإنسان على دراية
أن هذه الطاقة موجودة عنده
إلا إذا وضع في ظرف وفي موقف معين
هذا الموقف يتطلب منه أن يفتش، يفكر، يكتشف
ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل؟
كيف يمكنني أن أحل المشكلة التي أواجهها؟
أذكر بداية دخولي الجامعة،
أول سنة في الجامعة
كانت من أكبر التحديات التي تواجهني
مسألة الكتابة
كنت أغبط زملائي في الحقيقة
لأنهم يكتبون في دفاترهم
يكتبون بأقلامهم
وأنا أجلس مكتوف الأيدي
لا أكتب، لا أفعل أي شيء
وصراحةً كنت أستعين ببعض الأصدقاء
كانوا يساعدونني، يعطونني دفاترهم
لكن كان يصعب عليّ التعرف على الخطوط
بعض الرفاق يقرؤونها لي
أحيانا يكون الخط غير واضح
أو كنت أعتمد على التسجيل الصوتي
لكن مهما كان
كتابة المادة أمامك ليس كما الكتابة من فهمك
وطبعا كانت الحلول بالنسبة لي متوفرة
آلات "Perkins"، آلات الكتابة هذه موجودة
ولكن صوتها عالٍ جدا
تحدث ضجيج كبير جداً
فبحثت عن حل أبسط من هذا
قالوا لي أن دايان بلاسي طور جهازاً
عبارة عن "Notetaker"
عبارة عن جهاز فيه "Operating system" متكامل
صغير جداً، حجمه حجم علبة الغينكس تقريبا
مزود بنظام تشغيل
يسمح لي أن أكتب بهدوء
لم يصدر أي صوت في القاعة
ومزود بنظام تخزين المعلومات المكتوبة
على شكل ملفات طبعاً
ويمكنني أن أستدعي هذه الملفات في أي وقت
وفعلا استعنت بهذا الجهاز
أعطاني الكثير من الراحة
واستطعت فعلا أن أكتب وراء المحاضرين
وشعرت أني مثل باقي الطلاب تماماً
وبعد مرحلة زمنية معينة
لاحظت بأن سرعتي في الكتابة بهذا الجهاز
كانت عالية جداً
إلى درجة أنني كنت أفوق في سرعة الكتابة
زملائي المبصرين
ففكرت وقلت لنفسي: "هذا الحل أمامي.
لمذا لا أسخر هذه الإمكانية وأجهز الملفات
وأكتبها بشكل صحيح وأدققها
وأهيأها على شكل ملازم للطلاب
فحاولت ووصلت إلى حل
الجهاز يحتوي على "option" سمح لي بتحويل الصيغة
التي كنت أخزن فيها الملفات
إلى نص مقروء
فنزلتها على "floppy disk"
وأعطيتها لأحد الأصدقاء
وقلت له حاول طباعة هذه المعلومات من فضلك
وقام بطباعتها
وسألته : "كيف تبدو لك الكلمات؟ واضحة؟
قال لي: " نعم، ممتاز!"
قلت له: "قمت بكتابة وراء المحاضر"
أعجبوا في الحقيقة بهذا
وقالوا لي: "أحمد سنعتمد عليك
من اليوم فصاعداً!
سنعتمد عليك في كتابة الملازم الدراسية
وصرت فعلا أكتب الملازم الدراسية
لزملائي الطلاب من ذلك الوقت
فهذه إمكانية اكتشفتها في نفسي
ومتى اكتشفتها؟
عندما مررت بظرف صعب
احتجت أن أبحث عن شيء
أبحث عن حل لمشكلة كنت أعاني منها
وبالفعل تمكنت أن أصل إلى هذا الحل
وأستعنت بالتقنية التي ساعدتني على ذلك
حسناً، لنفترض أن أحدنا
تمكن من تخطي هذه المصاعب
وتمكن من تحقيق ما يصبو ويرمي إلى تحقيقه
وتمكن من الحصول على مؤهل أكاديمي معين
في الهندسة، في علوم الحاسب، مثلا
وفكر في خوض غمار الحياة العملية
عندها ستفكر في خوض غمار الحياة العملية
عليك أن تتوقع نوع آخر من المعوقات
ربما لا يكفيني الوقت لكي أذكرها كلها
ولكني سأذكر أهمها
السلوك السلبي لبعض الناس
أنا أسميهم "أعداء النجاح"
أنت تخرجت الآن من الجامعة مثلا
لديك مؤهل معين، مميز، ما شاء الله
وتبحث عن فرصة عمل في مؤسسة ما
وقابلك الشخص المسؤول
ورأى بانك لا زلت خريجاً جديداً
واستهان بقدراتك
و قال لك:" لا، عذراً أخي
ليس لديك الخبرة الكافية
وليس لديك الدراية التي تمكنك بالعمل،
إلى آخره
ولو قارنوا بينكم أصلا،
من الممكن أن تفوقه بكثير، تجعله يخجل
من الممكن أن ليس له دراية
بكثير من التقنيات
التي أنت على دراية بها
هذا يمكن أن يزرع فيك شيئاً من الإحباط
واليأس
خصوصا إذا التقيت بالكثير من هذه الشخصيات
أو مثلاً
أنت تكون خريجاً
وتفكر في مشروع معين
تفكر في تأسيس عمل حر مثلاً
وتستشير أهل الخبرة
ويروا بإنك مندفع
فيقولوا لك: "لا يا أخي هذا المشروع
من الممكن أن تخسر فيه
وأصلا السوق مشبع الآن
ومليئ بالمشاريع المماثلة
وليس هنالك شيء يميزك عن الآخرين"
فيزرعون فيك الخوف من الفشل
فتتوقف
فأنا أنصح: "لا تأبهوا لمثل هؤلاء
لو أن شخص لم يعثر على فرصة عمل مناسبة
هذا قد يكون دافع له
لكي يواصل مسيرته الأكاديمية
يكمل في الدراسات العليا
يحصل على دكتوراه
يتميز على الشخص الذي منعه من العمل
إذا حاول أحدهم أن يقلل من شأن هذا المشروع
دعهم يتعرفوا على إمكانية نجاح هذا الأمر
لأنك أنت الشخص المتخصص
الشخص الأقرب إلى هذا الميدان
الذي تريد أن تؤسس مشروعك فيه
لنفرض أن هذا الشخص أسس مشروعه
وتمكن من بناء مؤسسة أو شركة
ويريد فعلاً أن تتميز هذه الشركة
عن المؤسسات والشركات الأخرى
كيف يمكنني أن أصنع وأجعل
من شركتي أو مؤسستي
جهة ناجحة تتميز
عن بقية الشركات وبقية المؤسسات؟
الكثير من الأمور يلم بها أهل المعرفة
ولكنني صراحةً أركز على الجانب
الذي يتضمن تذليل المعوقات
الجانب الذي يشمل تذليل المعوقات عن الناس
يتوجب عليّ أن أفكر في ثلاثة أمور:
أولاً، كيف يمكنني أن أخلق بيئة عمل مثالية
بيئة عمل صديقة للكل
مرحبة بالجميع
لا تميز بين الأعضاء الموجودين فيها
على أساس اللون
أو على أساس العرق
أو على أساس الجنس
فيها "diversity"
فيها تنوع بشري
من كل الأجناس
من كل فئات المجتمع
فيها معاقين
فيها كبار السن
فيها ناس مؤهلين طبعا للعمل
كيف يمكنني أن أخلق هذه البيئة؟
ثانياً، يجب أن أفكر
في التسهيل على المتعاملين
كيف يمكنني أن أسهل على المتعامل
الذي يمكن أن يتقدم لي
من الممكن أن يأتيني شخص كبير السن
أو شخص على"wheel chair" كرسي متحرك
يحتاج إلى تهيئة المرافق المحيطة
يتوجب عليّ أن أأخذ بعين الاعتبار
كل الفئات التي قد تأتيني
و تستفيد من خدماتي
لأن الكثير من المؤسسات
الكثير من الشركات
الكثير من المصارف
الكثير من شركات الإتصالات
وغيرها من منافذ الخدمات
لا يأخذون بعين الاعتبار
هذه الفئات المستضعفة
التي لا يلتفت لها أحد
والشركات التي تحوز على الجوائز،
جوائز تميز، جوائز الجودة
هي دائما شركات تراعي خصوصية هذه الفئات
ثالثا، لابد أن أفكر في المنتج
الذي أقدمه للناس
أن أراعي في تصميمه
أنه كيف يمكنني أن أصمم منتج
يفي باحتياجات جميع الناس
بصرف النظرعن أي اعتبار
قد يقع هذا المنتج في يد شخص
لا يستطيع أن يقرأ مثلا
أضع "label" معين، مثلاً، أكبر الخط ..
من أسباب نجاح شركة "Apple"
في الآونة الأخيرة
تبنوا مفهوم "universal design"
هذا المفهوم يقضي بأن أنا أصمم منتجاتي
وفق احتياجات جميع مستخدميها
فمثلاً جميع الأجهزة
سوى أن كان محمل فيها "IOS" أو "MacBooks"
التي فيها "Osx operating systems"
هي مزودة بشيء يدعى "universal access"
هو عبارة عن حزمة من البرامج فيها نظام صوتي
يسمح لذوي الإعاقة البصرية من استخدام
جميع تطبيقات نظام التشغيل
وفيها أيضا مكبر للحروف
وبرنامج آخر لمساعدة من يعانون
من مشاكل في السمع
فتخيلوا حجم الفائدة الكبيرة
التي جنتها بعض الفئات
نتيجة تطبيق مفهوم "universal design"
أعطيكم مثال بسيط
وهو " I-vox" و"Amazon kindle"
التي يمكنك تحميلها على "IOS devices"
تخيلوا يا جماعة بوجود "screen readers"
مع هذه "apps"
التي تعتبر منافذ لمكتبات كبيرة
فيها ملايين الكتب
في يوم و ليلة فُتح هذا المجال
لذوي الإعاقة البصرية
يقرؤون ملايين الكتب
بعدما كانت مصادر القراءة محدودة جداً
لا تتعدى عشرات الآلاف
فاستطعنا توفير وصول لملايين الكتب
بسبب أمر بسيط
ربما لم يكن في مخيلة الكثير من الشركات
وهو مفهوم "universal design"
إنك أنت تضع "screen reader"،
تضع "magnification" مثلاً، "software"
ومفهوم "universal design"
لا يشمل بالضرورة فقط على الأجهزة والمنتجات
من الممكن أن يشمل على البيئة المحيطة أيضا
كيف يمكنني أن أقدم أو أصمم مبناي
بطريقة تتوافق مع إحتياجات كل مستخدميها؟
أريد أن أختم حديثي هذا بأمرين
الأمر الأول:
الأمس كنت أتصفح "Twitter"
مررت بتغريدة جميلة
للشيخ الأخضرالشيخ عبد العزيز النعيمي
التي قد تلخص باختصار شديد كل كلامي
والتغريدة تقول:
سر العظمة هو العمل بلا يأس
والمثابرة بلا فتور
وأخيراً وليس بآخراً
أجدد شكري لجميع الإخوة
الذين عملوا على إعداد
وتنظيم هذا الحدث
وأشكركم على حسن إصغائكم
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته